[Musique]
edun est atteint de la maladie de crabes
une sorte de low cost revit qui
progresse à une vitesse fulgurante qui
le paralyse
l' empêche de manger en quelques mois et
donne est devenu prisonnier à
l'intérieur de son propre corps c'est
horrible ce qu'on vit vraiment c'est
j'avais accepté que mon fils est un
handicap quand j'ai eu le diagnostic je
m'attendais pas à ce que maintenant ce
que mon fils allait mourir
passée la monde qui s'écroule c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment horrible on a
envie de chercher on a envie de
s'investir pour ces maladies ces images
nous les avons tourné il y a un an et
demi à l'époque et de ne n'était qu'une
poupée de chiffon
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le petit garçon arrive à se
tenir à quatre pattes une lueur d'espoir
pour cet enfant pourtant atteint d'une
maladie neurodégénérative c'est faux là
vous l'avez vu l'année passée c'était
littéralement ça faisait un mois à peine
qu'il était sous protocole de l'eau il
était littéralement une poupée de
chiffon
depuis un an et 2 suit le protocole de
loups régime alimentaire concocté par
linda mari la maman de louis qui était
lui même atteint 2,7 l'uqo dystrophie
pour nourrir son petit louis linda mari
s'était inspiré de la diète que certains
médecins recommandent aux patients
atteints de la sclérose en plaques
un menu qui dosent lipides protéines et
antioxydants il n'y a retrouvé la vue et
retrouver la préhension a été capable de
manger y est capable d'avaler même
délicate parce que là ça fonctionne pull
à un certain niveau et un contenu ce que
vous faites il ya plus de médicaments il
souffre pas il sourit yp l'art y voit la
maladie demeure fatale le petit louis
s'est éteint à l'âge de trois ans et
demi
mais les progrès qu'il a réalisés durant
sa courte vie inspire aujourd'hui
plusieurs familles d'enfants atteints
par cette terrible maladie
le protocole de louer suivi maintenant
par ses enfants dans le monde dont un
polonais un anglais et quatre français
qu'on observe c'est un confort dit
mission de les placer en fait on n'a pas
refait au tamis tv l'une est mon petit
poulet et dun morgan et leurs familles
sont retournés vivre en france mais
morgane et linda mari reste
régulièrement en contact
alors alors qu'il est censé être une
poupée de chiffon
c'est tout juste c'est tout juste
incroyable a relevé le défi bravo matin
de passeurs ensemble elles continuent le
combat contre la maladie à la porte du
laboratoire du professeur mounier à
l'uqam
une plaque a été installée en l'honneur
de hayden et de louis hon l'instant
l'important c'est la preuve de concept
mais il faut absolument la avancé sur
cette preuve de concept la grâce aux
dons qu'elles ont amassé les deux maires
finance depuis un an les travaux de
recherche du professeur mounier une
marie morgane ont travaillé très fort
puis l'argentin beaucoup de morgan en
france qui a fait des levées de fonds il
ya une grosse partie de l'argent qui a
été versé donc dans mon laboratoire
d'ici quelques années
les chercheurs devraient comprendre
l'impact de la diète du protocole de
loups sur la maladie de crabes
on a réussi avec du travail en
collaboration entre gaëtan et linda
marée de trouver la diète optimale c'est
un des buts est extrêmement important
comme au laboratoire des travaux de
recherche vont bon train linda marie a
voulu mener encore plus loin son combat
contre la maladie de crabes
maintenant que la mise en place pour
l'excellent sur le protocole de l'oua
est faite au laboratoire du métabolisme
des lipides avec docteur monnier je
voulais un petit peu plus grand c'est à
dire plus grave ce sont toutes les
leucodystrophies nécessairement et on a
une sommité au canada ici à montréal à
25 minutes de chez moi qui s'appelle
docteur geneviève bernard va rien alors
il
ils ne sont pas au top de mon
laboratoire de recherche vraiment
laboratoire classique de recherche le
travail sur le pourquoi une rallonge en
cause la maladie
dr bernard s'intéresse non seulement à
la maladie crabes mais bien à l'ensemble
des leucodystrophies
son laboratoire à l'hôpital pour enfants
travaillent non seulement à soulager et
soutenir les malades et leurs familles
la chercheuse a l'ambition de trouver
une thérapie contre cette terrible
maladie
on travaille le plus vite qu'on peut
avec les sous qu'on ne la fatalité c'est
souvent nice ou affaire qui on a
d'argent plus on va vite l'argent
demeure le nerf de la guerre
docteur bernard doit consacrer 70 % de
son temps à chercher du financement pour
soutenir ses efforts linda mari a décidé
de quitter l'enseignement pour devenir
l'assistante de recherche au laboratoire
si on peut l'un l'a laissé faire ce
qu'elle a à faire et c'est là que mon
rôle prend toute sa place
aller chercher des fonds auprès du
public d'aller chercher des fonds aux
partout on peut auprès de commanditaires
après avoir rencontré le docteur bernard
morgane la maman redden a elle aussi
décidé de dédier les 300 bénévoles de la
fondation lueur d'espoir pourrait donne
on profite de la chercheuse la
détermination des deux mers fait
progresser la science
elles ont tous les deux premiers à leur
fils de tout faire en sorte pour un jour
vaincre cette horrible maladie